scientists on the spanish island la
palma are monitoring the air for toxic
gases being released as lava from the
erupting volcano empties into the
atlantic the reaction is sending acidic
vapor into the air for now winds are
carrying the gases out to sea but
islanders the locals they're worried
that that situation could change
the steaming lava makes for an
impressive spectacle but people are
being warned to keep their distance
since wednesday night lava with a
temperature of around 1 000 degrees
celsius has been flowing into the sea
the good news is that the plumes of
toxic gases created when molten lava
hits salty water have so far been blown
out to sea
but experts remain vigilant
the gases will have to be monitored we
have to bear in mind that each liter of
sea water contains 35 grams of sodium
chloride so large quantities are now
evaporating from the sea forming
hydrochloric acid which is harmful for
people's health
a curfew therefore remains in place in
several locations there's growing
concern because the wind that has so far
been fanning the toxic steam out to sea
has now weakened
residents have been urged to stay
indoors
i can't smell anything and i don't feel
any different the ash is annoying
because of the breeze that's blowing
but for others it's tough
many of the banana plantations that are
key to the economy of the canary islands
have been destroyed the lava has also
blocked access to the plantations that
remain
it's a total disaster yesterday we
couldn't water the plants it's the same
today
we have to drive almost halfway around
the island to get to work but right now
we have no other choice
the lava that is still spewing from the
cumbre vieja volcano has engulfed around
470 hectares of land and destroyed
nearly 800 houses in its path out to sea
but as the lava starts to cool in the
sea it's creating new land as a result
the island of la palma has already grown
by about 10 hectares
our correspondent nicole riss is on la
palma tonight
it's here behind me where the lava is
finally meeting the sea and this creates
an enormous amount of possibly very
toxic clouds which is also why residents
close to this area in a perimeter of 3.5
kilometers are currently confined to
their homes they're advised not to leave
their houses to seal their doors and
windows and to wait for more information
coming from scientists and local
authorities and it's this very lava that
we see coming into the sea right here
that has been making its way from the
cumbria vieja volcano for over a week
now destroying more than 815 buildings a
path of destruction for sure and we got
a little taste of that just earlier when
we tried out a different position and it
suddenly started hailing down on us
small volcanic pebbles pebble-like
stones that were coming out at us it was
a very
interesting situation to say the least
but it gives you an idea of how
dangerous it can be the closer you get
to this volcano some locals even said
that the kumbreva volcano is like a
monster and that it destroys everything
that's in its way and this monster may
rumble on for a few weeks or even for a
few months